so this is day two or we have just past
day two of Cavanaugh's hearing
confirmation hearings in the Senate and
they're over I think about what eight
hours nine hours of testimony that took
place or of question and answering that
took place today and we're not even
going to attempt to give you a summary
of it because it was so long you could
get a summary somewhere else I want to
highlight about three clips that were
very telling exchanges that told us more
than Cavanaugh ever wanted us to know
about him this first clip is between
senator Feinstein and Cavanaugh asking
him how does he reconcile his position
regarding weapons like ar-15s being
common weapons and the damage that they
caused particularly in mass shootings
specifically in school shootings take a
listen all right how do you reconcile
what you've just said with the hundreds
of school shootings using assault
weapons that have taken place in recent
history how do you reconcile that Center
of course the the violence in the
schools is something we all detest and
want to do something about and there are
lots of efforts I know underway to make
schools safer I know I know it my girls
school they do a lot of things now that
are different than they did just a few
years ago in terms of trying to harden
the school and make it safer for
everyone alright so as you can see in
this clip he completely dismisses the
reality that these weapons are the
weapon of choice that are used to kill
innocent people
these he ships the burden the
responsibility of protecting our
children not on to legislators or judges
but unto schools who have to quote
unquote harden their facilities
you know that's that lets you know that
you already knew this right I'm
stammering because it is obscene despite
the fact that we know exactly who he is
you know it's something when you can get
on a national stage and and essentially
wear a banner saying I have been
purchased by the NRA or maybe his banner
more precisely would say I'm sponsored
by the NRA but here he's demonstrating
in whether he wanted to or not he
thought that he was prevaricated and he
thought he was getting around it but
actually what he let he let it be known
that if you want your children to be
safe don't look to legislators don't
look to leaders you better hard in your
school don't look to getting rid of the
guns don't look to even you know
controlling assault rifles the ar-15
don't look towards that Hardin near
facilities because it's more important
to him that he protects the ability of
gun owners to get ar-15s than it is for
him to be even concerned about the
people who are killed because of that
weapon now that was the first exchange
the second exchange comes with Kamala
Harris comes from Kamala Harris and all
I can say is damn can you think of any
laws that give government the power to
make decisions about the male body I'm
happy to answer a more specific question
but male versus female there are medical
procedures I mean the government that
the government has the power to make a
decision about a man's body I thought
you were asking about medical procedures
that are unique to men I can I'll repeat
the question can you think of any laws
that give the government the power to
make decisions about the male body I'm
not a I'm not a thinking of any right
now senator I don't think I've ever
heard that question asked and it's so
simple and yet so precise can you tell
us any law that regulates
men's bodies but here he is whether he
admits it or not which he's not going to
admit it he has one task I never keep
going off on these tangents but it's
there I want to it's hard because you
tried to argue these these these issues
in good faith within the framework
that's given questions and answers but
in the backdrop of my mind and yours do
you know who this clown is you know who
this man really is he is an he's a rabid
evangelical leaning activist
conservative judge that at the moment he
gets the opportunity he's going to do
away with bro versus Wade yet he's
sitting here and in question an answer
setting and we are expected to entertain
him in this civilized format when in
reality we know exactly who the hell
this clown is but back to the point the
point is I don't think I've ever heard
anyone ask a question that's the sink
and to the point and he could not answer
it
he has this way you know when he's lying
or when he doesn't want to answer you'll
see even more so in a minute he could
tell he does not want to answer this
question because he's acting as though
he couldn't hear it correctly right he
does the same thing in this next clip
we're gonna break this next clip up into
two segments it's the same clip but it's
a little long but I absolutely need you
to hear it here's the first part judge
have you ever discussed special counsel
Muller or his investigation with anyone
well it's in the news every day I have
you discussed it with anyone with other
judges I know have you discussed Muller
or his investigation with anyone at
Kassovitz Benson and Torres the law firm
founded by Mark caso its president
Trump's personal lawyer be sure about
your answer sir well I'm not remembering
but if you have something you wanna are
you certain you've not had a
conversation about anyone at that
Kazu miss benson Casa wits Benson and
Torres which is the law firm founded by
Mark Casa wits who is president Trump's
personal lawyer are you have you had any
conversation about robert muller or his
investigation with anyone at that firm
yes or no Wow
I mean that's all I could say Kamala
Harris Wow
I've never really been like a huge fan
of prosecutors because of their role in
our in justice system but her
prosecutorial skills came to bear just
answer the question Brett Kavanaugh yes
or no I mean that was that was amazing
and you can see just like I mentioned
before that when he doesn't want to
answer a question he likes to play dumb
when in reality he prides himself on his
ability to remember the most minut
detail the most a statement that is
inconsequential in our minds he
remembers it from every decision from
from every opinion from every court and
yet he gets to this question and he he
starts shifting around and stammering
that means he's lying but here's the
best half take a look at this next half
well is there a person you're talking
I'm asking you a very direct question
yes or no I need to know the I'm not
sure I know everyone who works at that
law firm I don't think you need to I
think you need to know who you talked
with who'd you talk to
I don't think I I'm not remembering but
I'm happy to be refreshed or if you want
to tell me who you're sorry are you
saying that with all that you remember
you have an impeccable memory you've
been speaking for almost eight hours I
think more with this committee about all
sorts of things you remember how can you
not remember whether or not you had a
conversation about robert muller or his
investigation with anyone at that law
firm
I don't investigation is all even
going on for so long sir right I'm not
sure I do i I'm just trying to think do
I know anyone who works that firm I
might know yeah that's not my question
my question is have you had a
conversation with anyone at that firm
about that investigation it's a really
specific question I would like to know
the person you're thinking of because
what if they're I think you're thinking
of someone you don't want to tell us who
did you have a conversation with if I am
mr. chairman I I'd like to raise an
objection here again like Kamala Harris
and I like what she's doing because
she's not really putting on a show a lot
of people grandstand whether it be from
the pro or the opposition side it
doesn't matter you see a lot of
grandstanding but here she's got a line
of questioning she has something she's
done her research and even if she hasn't
done her research and she's just
bluffing she's bluffing the hell out of
this man and she's doing it in a
spectacular fashion that isn't coming
off as grandstanding as much as it is
her being a prosecutorial monster in the
most flattering way that I could say
that phrase call someone a monster but I
digress the point is she did a killer
job so much so that a Republican had to
object that is a type of questioning
that we need all of the time but
especially right now and one question
that I want one of the Democrats to ask
is simply this Kavanagh if you really
trust and believe in your work why don't
you voluntarily turn over those
documents those documents that
Republicans are withholding if they ask
them that question I would love to see
the answer